el Primer Ministro Israel y Benjamín
netanyahu tomaduras medidas en respuesta
los dos ataques perpetrados por
palestinos en Jerusalén en un consejo de
seguridad decidió entre otras medidas
sellar la casa del hombre que disparó
cerca a una sinagoga el pasado jueves y
que terminó con la vida de siete
personas así como revocar algunos
derechos de las familias de quienes
consideran terroristas y nuevos
asentamientos en Jerusalén este
esta mañana hemos presentado la casa del
terrorista que perpetró el atroz
atentado de Jerusalén y más adelante su
vivienda será demolida decidimos denegar
los derechos de seguridad social a las
familias que apoyan el terror y el
gobierno discutirá otras medidas entre
ellas la revocación de los documentos de
identidad y la revocación de la
residencia a las familias de los
terroristas que apoyan el terror
familiares del atacante respondieron a
la medida de Israel
la sellaron por dentro Nadie puede
entrar si a veces nos impiden entrar en
la propia mezquita de alacsa nos va a
importar una casa Cuánto cuesta
horas después del tiroteo mortal frente
a la sinagoga un niño palestino de 13
años disparó e hirió a dos israelíes A
las afueras de la ciudad vieja
amurallada del este de Jerusalén los
atentados en la ciudad ocurrieron tras
una incursión Armada Israel y en yin si
es Jordania la más mortífera en décadas
donde nueve palestinos murieron según
Israel buscaban integrantes de las
yihadislámica la comunidad internacional
llama a un cese en las hostilidades